les limites aux politiques bonsoir et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous du dimanche soir sur radio
sensations en association avec tv 118
non invité ce soir et le secrétaire
départemental debout la france des
yvelines olivier galland
[Musique]
de politique
olivier galland bonsoir merci bonsoir
vous êtes habitants de saint cyr l'école
dans les yvelines vous avez rejoint en
2010 est debout la france le parti mené
par nicolas dupont aignan alors vous
êtes secrétaire départemental depuis
deux ans pourquoi en 2007 avoir fait ce
choix de rejoindre debout la france
lors des débats des présentations
politique de chaque candidat un soir ma
fille m'appelle et me dit papa il ya un
monsieur à la télé il pense comme toi
alors j'ai regardé et j'ai découvert
nicolas dupont aignan est effectivement
nous avons une convergence dans nos
pensées
j'ai laissé passer la campagne et puis
quelques mois après j'ai assisté à une
réunion politique des yvelines de debout
la france ça m'a plu je me suis inscrit
et puis je suis resté depuis il vous est
donc devenu ensuite secrétaire
départemental nicolas dupont aignan a
fait 4 70% des voix en 2017 récoltant un
million six cent quatre-vingt quinze
mille bulletins ils s'étaient alliés
ensuite à marine le pen lors du de
l'entre-deux tours il devait devenir
même son premier ministre à l'époque
pourtant l'alliance a tourné court
aujourd'hui selon vous pourquoi nicolas
dupont aignan est le mieux placé pour
devenir le prochain président de la
république écoutez si on regarde les
sondages même si on leur fait dire un
peu ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui aucun
candidat n'est capable de battre
monsieur mâcon
chacun est dans son camp chacun regarde
regarde pour lui nicolas dupont aignan
propose
un programme qui va permettre à chacun
de le rejoindre il appelle tous les
autres candidats à le rejoindre et
et pour nous il a une opportunité de
remporter la présidentielle dans ces
conditions dans leur cas c'est le seul
l'offre politique s'est densifié
notamment avec la candidature d'eric
zemmour vous n'avez pas peur que
quelques ares trop de boue la france des
débats
alors eric zemmour fait fait tous les
plateaux télé et fait des records
d'antenne actuellement il fait il fait
des meetings il fait parler de lui mais
c'est un homme c'est un homme de
télévision un homme de
pas de spectacle mais en tout cas il
sait il sait parler aux médias
et puis les médias après 6 a également
eu un petit peu de polémique
c'est un homme cultivé donc donc oui il
nous fait de l'ombre actuellement on est
là pour parler du programme de debout la
france on va rentrer un peu plus dans le
détail du projet de nicolas dupont
aignan mais d'abord comment est ce qu a
évolué ce projet depuis 2010 est
la situation de la france a évolué
depuis 2010 est avant les élections de
2017 on ne savait pas ce qui allait
faire monsieur macron
maintenant on l'a vu la crise sanitaire
qui est arrivé et puis beaucoup de
décisions qu'ils soient qui sont venus
les unes après les autres et qui ne nous
conviennent pas donc nous proposons une
véritable alternative
à la politique actuelle et puis surtout
alors voilà monsieur du poignet en sorti
un livre il n'ya pas très longtemps
en vente dans toutes les bonnes
librairies
nous proposons le financement de ce
programme voilà ce sont des propositions
chiffrées et à chaque fois on va dire où
on va chercher l'argent pour les
réaliser alors sur l'europe d'abord vous
souhaitez transformer l'union européenne
par une communauté des états européens
pas de fric sic donc mais dans les faits
à quoi ressemblerait cette nouvelle
communauté européenne que vous souhaitez
on avait une analogie a pas très
longtemps avec un avec un immeuble avec
un syndic de copropriété et le but c'est
que tout le monde ne s'entendent bien
dans l'immeuble avec des règles et ainsi
de suite mais je n'ai pas obligés de
connaître tout le monde dans l'immeuble
on n'est pas obligés de s'entendre bien
avec tous tous les habitants de
l'immeuble par contre nos voisins de
palier eh bien on les voit on mange
ensemble et puis et puis on s'arrange
dans ma rue c'est pareil hein j'ai des
voisins qui sont en face de moi
genre un des petits services les membres
des services on se dit bonjour on se
connaît bien et voilà et ce sont des
liens entre personnes entre groupes et
c'est pas parce que il y à la mairie à
côté et la ville qu' il n'y a pas de
lien entre les deux donc la ville elle a
elle même plat certains règlements les
ordures ménagères la circulation mais
les liens entre entre habitants c'est
aux habitants de le faire en de le faire
eux-mêmes laura debout la france vous
êtes favorable à la primauté du droit
national sur le droit européen
vous pouvez nous expliquer pour quelles
raisons
on n'est pas certain que ce qui se
décide à
bruxelles et puis à la cour de justice
européenne par exemple
side ans dans l'intérêt dans l'intérêt
des peuples et en particulier des
français voilà il ya des lois qui sont
qui sont votées et qui n'intéresse
personne
par contre on les applique et
les français n'y gagne rien et un
exemple est pas très longtemps vous avez
suivi le cours de l'énergie de
l'électricité sur le marché bah c'est
bruxelles qui a décidé ça enfin les les
pays européens regroupés qui ont décidé
ça le tarif se fait sur la dernière
centrale qui est mise en place une
centrale à gaz donc donc le le prix
l'énergie a augmenté ça n'intéresse pas
les français nous on a une énergie
principalement nucléaire une électricité
principalement nucléaire et on devrait
pouvoir avoir nos prix à nous dicter en
fonction de nos besoins et de notre
capacité vous renoncerez aux grands
accords de libre-échange tels que le taf
taf des états unis où le ceta avec le
canada pour vous c'est dans la même
boutique c'est absolument étaient qu'à
leur sont bons à l'encontre des peuples
c'est à l'encontre des français en tout
cas à l'encontre des peuples européens
également
vous savez ces traités on va on va faire
venir deux la nourriture de la viande
par exemple que d'autres pays avec des
transports maritimes important et puis
des conditions d'élevage qui sont qui
n'ont pas de rapport avec ce que les
normes les normes qui est dans notre
pays donc
c'est de la nourriture qui est peut-être
pas de moins bonne qualité mais
peut-être moins scène qu'on va faire
venir en france et au détriment de
l'agriculture française et en
contrepartie il ya du libre échange va
pouvoir exporter vers vers ces pays là
mais je suis pas certain que les
français il ya un grand chose
rené enfin abandon de ces traités autre
mesure où souhaitait suspendre
immédiatement l'espace schengen les
frontières gérée à l'échelle européenne
n'ont pas prouvé leur efficacité selon
alors elles ont même prouvé leur
inefficacité
j'entendais encore l'allemagne qui
proposent de faire venir quatre cents
400 milles immigrants en en allemagne
prochainement il n'y a pas de frontière
à l'intérieur donc ces personnes qui
vont être accueillies en allemagne à
vont venir en france ou dans les autres
pays chacun voit sa politique
mes mails impose aux autres beaucoup à
la il n'y a pas de ya pas de sécurité
aux frontières extérieures il n'y a plus
de frontières intérieures donc c'est pas
trés c'est pas efficace du tout quand
vous souhaitez créer une union
méditerranéenne afin de réaliser une
politique de co-développement avec tous
les pays autour de la méditerranée et de
régler les problèmes qui s'y passe
aujourd'hui il ya un manque de dialogue
entre les pays méditerranéens
absolument
je sais pas de quoi de quoi on discute
on discute
chacun de sa politique intérieure de
deux des programmes électoraux qui vise
à
exacerber les tensions
nicolas dupont aignan ya pas très
longtemps
travaillé dans une dans une commission à
l'assemblée sur la pollution de la
méditerranée
voilà ça c'est un vrai sujet la
pollution de la méditerranée
chacun
pollue un petit peu mais mais sans s'en
préoccuper
la france pourrait faire une union
méditerranéenne
et traiter ce sujet donc les pays de la
méditerranée que ce soit l'espagne la
france la grèce dont des pays européens
mais également des pays du maghreb pour
s entendre et plutôt que de financer on
donne de l'argent à des pays africains
ou autres sans regarder ce qui se passe
derrière on pourrait travailler avec
avec ces pays là pour mettre en place
des stations d'épuration tout un système
qui éviterait de polluer la méditerranée
voilà ça c'est un vrai projet et c'est
un projet qui se fait entre acteurs donc
ça se décide pas au niveau de l'europe
ça se décide pas au niveau de l'afrique
ça se dit ça se décide autour d'une
table avec les quelques pays qui sont
concernés alors pour continuer sur
l'idée de co développement vous proposez
aussi le lancement d'un plan marshall
pour l'afrique alors quels seront les
grands objectifs de ce plan c'est le
devoir de la france que d'être de
l'afrique alors la france ne sera pas
tout seul j'espère les états unis ont
financé le plan marshall après après la
seconde guerre mondiale mais c'étaient
les états unis il faut il faut l'en il
faut lancer un projet
en mai c'était il ya cinq mois six mois
on l'a déjà oublié
emmanuel macron a dit qu'il annulait la
dette du soudan 1 4 milliard d'euros
traités par la france qui ont qui ont
été annulés pour les aider dans leur
transition
vers plus de démocratie quatre mois
après coup d'état il ya plus de
démocratie voilà donc c'est de l'argent
4 milliards c'est énorme qui a été donné
comme ça un pays sans vraiment de
contrepartie sans vraiment de projet et
c'est exactement le contraire de ce
qu'on veut nous on veut aider les pays à
investir dans l'est dans leurs économies
à investir dans leurs infrastructures
donc ça c'est un vrai projet on les aide
financièrement mais on regarde ce qui se
passe derrière et le but c'est que tout
le monde soit gagnant de ces pays là ils
vont ils ils ont commercé ensuite avec
la france ferait on travaillera ensemble
ils aimeront la france c'est gagnant
gagnant
autre thème à présent qui est revenu sur
le devant de l'actualité avec la
situation aux antilles c'est les
outre-mer alors vous militez pour la
mise en oeuvre d'une stratégie nationale
de promotion des atouts de l'outremer
est une véritable continuité
territoriale avec l'hexagone alors
qu'est ce que ça signifie cependant
cette stratégie nationale mia va conseil
national il ya deux semaines à hyères
oblige il était avec un certain nombre
de délégués et puis il y avait la
représentante debout la france de
l'outre-mer qui étaient là et capri
l'ombre à la parole et donc on a pu
beaucoup discuté avec elle donc on a un
projet et puis il ya des constats alors
la promotion des atouts de l'outremer
globalement
pour nous ça va être une stratégie
nationale
l'outre-mer c'est la france c'est
vraiment la france à l'ultra marin un
guadeloupéen ou un an bretons c'est la
même c'est le même type de deux citoyens
il n'y a pas de différence entre les
deux simplement ils sont plus loin ils
sont plus loin donc on les voit moins
plus du décalage horaire enfin plus un
certain nombre de facteurs mais ça c'est
techniques nouveaux et une vraie
stratégie nationale pour remettre en
avant l'outre-mer de manière générale
alors trois atouts principalement une
économie maritime
grâce à l'autre mère on a des eaux
territoriales on doit être le premier ou
le deuxième pays au monde sur sur nos
eaux territoriales un atout très
important le tourisme même avec le co
vide le tourisme doit continuer à se
développer
c'est un facteur de développement majeur
et puis et puis c'est le rêve de des
gens de la métropole d'aller passer des
vacances alors je parle je vais pas les
listes et mais en guadeloupe ou en
martinique
et puis l'agriculture enfin
l'agriculture alors on voit il ya eu des
produits chimiques qui ont été utilisés
en guadeloupe ça fait un scandale
sanitaire
c'est c'est assez déplorable que la
métropole ce soit conduite comme ça mais
si je prends l'exemple du sucre par
exemple du sucre de canne et bien c'est
un bon produit c'est bon pour la santé
il faut le mettre en avant et inciterait
donc stratégie nationale de mise en
avant des atouts de
de l'outre-mer un général j'ai noté
quelques points quelques mesures que
vous souhaitez donc mettre en oeuvre
pour les outremers vous souhaitez
augmenter la part des enseignements
consacré à l'histoire et la géographie
des départements et des collectivités
d'outre-mer dans le programme de
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui c'est
un oubli c'est c'est un manque de
l'éducation nationale je crois qu'il ya
un personnage politique de premier plan
qui avait parlé de la guyane comme d'une
île il ya quelques il ya quelques années
oui la géographie on la géographie de
l'hexagone on en apprend la dessiner
dans les petites classes on apprend les
fleuves on apprend les cours d'eau
qui connaît le nom de des cours d'eau
qui en guyane c'est ma grande exemple
pas grand monde qui sait que la guyane a
une frontière avec le brésil par exemple
voilà nous les brésiliens sont nos
voisins et puis grandes terres basses
terres
où elle pointe à pitre c'est à quelle
distance voilà il ya beaucoup de choses
à apprendre à nos enfants et c'est un
beau sujet c'est un beau sujet
d'enseignement alors autres autre idée
vous proposé d'inclure les prévisions
météorologiques des autres maires dans
les toutes les météos des chaînes
nationales alors ça peut sembler
anecdotique mais c'est important pour le
symbole d'inclure c'est ses prévisions
métérologiques
cc2 manière générale
une stratégie un projet national de
continuité territoriale
alors on met la météo de la corse voilà
il va faire telles températures ajaccio
eh bien on peut mettre la météo y
compris de saint pierre et miquelon
alors debout la france on va changer de
sujet debout la france s'engage aussi
pour le bien-être animal pour vous ce
n'est pas un sujet annexe c'est un sujet
qui compte écoutez j'ai pris la parole
au conseil national vous le voyez c'est
la bonne personne pour cette discussion
pour parler des animaux
alors il ya une petite mesure
si vous l'avez dans notre dans notre
feuillets sur
sur un sujet qui est majeure en france
c'est les cent mille animaux qui sont
abandonnés tous les ans
c'est ça incroyable manger des animaux
personnellement quand je pars en
vacances je me pose la question de ce
que je vais faire mes animaux est ce que
je les emmène parce qu'ils vont être
bien est-ce que je les laisse à la
maison je prends un pet sitter ou un
voisin ainsi de suite l'abandon des
animaux c'est quelque chose qu'on
voulait contre lequel il faut se battre
et plusieurs choses à faire pour ça et
puis et puis
j'ai pas si vous avez déjà eu quelques
relations avec 30 millions d'amis par
exemple tous les ans il ya des campagnes
aidez-nous financièrement on a plus de
sous les refuges sont débordés dans
notre dans notre projet il y à garantir
le financement des associations et des
refuges ça c'est à ces femmes c'est
vraiment très important après il ya
beaucoup de choses donc lutter contre
les animaux
et aider aux soins pour les animaux la
vaccination ça coûte 100 euros tout le
monde a pas 100 euros dépensés pour tous
les ans plus pour faire vacciner son
chien et son chat donc il fait daniel je
dois faire la loi la stérilisation c'est
très important on parle de chat de chats
errants et de à une stérilisation ça
coûte 200 euros tout le monde peut pas
faire faire stériliser comme ça son
animal donc il faut qu'il y ait des
aides il faut qu'il y ait un programme
ça c'est pour les animaux de compagnie
mais il ya également les animaux
d'élevage
voilà donc ce qu'on souhaite mettre en
place ces des élevages de qualité les
élevages de qualité ça veut ça veut dire
des animaux qui sont qui sont pas dans
des cages des animaux qui sont qui sont
plus en liberté un label bien être
animal qui serait décerner
un label élevé en france on avait une
polémique a pas très longtemps sur les
étiquettes pour le lait la fabrication
française aux productions françaises
s'étaient on voulait mettre où je sais
pas c'est d'ailleurs une étiquette
européens la place de français ça ça n'a
pas de sens le lay ici vient de chez
nous il vient de chez nous de nos
agriculteurs de nos éleveurs et puis il
ya la problématique des abattoirs les
abattoirs on entend parler tous les
trois mois quand quand une association
sur une vidéo on a l'impression que le
lendemain de la vidéo le préfet est
intervenue et puis tout est réglé mais
ce n'est pas le cas donc pour les
abattoirs mise en place de normes
sévères application de ces normes
vidéosurveillance des contrôles inopinés
de l'inspection sanitaire et puis pas
d'abattage sans étourdissement en tout
cas pour alimenter les services de
restauration des municipalités
et puis à côté de ça importer des
animaux français que les éleveurs qui
art est d'apporter des animaux mais il
achète des animaux français et puis un
petit point anecdotique mais mais vu
l'endroit où nous sommes c'est quand
même intéressant on est pour le
développement de fermes pédagogiques
fins pédagogiques
il ya la ferme de gally chez pas si vous
connaissez c'est pas très loin on y va
le dimanche je ne vois là dans les
yvelines côté de saint cyr on y va le
dimanche
les enfants voient les animaux ils
fondent ils peuvent d'activité pour
faire du beurre ou là je fais un petit
peu leur publicité et une autre ferme
pédagogique
sur au niveau des étangs de 50 ha voilà
à côté de la réserve naturelle donc ça
apprend aux enfants
autre chose qu'un chien chasse alors ça
leur montre les animaux de la ferme on
peut également voir les oiseaux et ainsi
de suite donc il ya cette notion de
pédagogie de leur montrer qu'un animal
c'est pas quelque chose qui points 9
c'est vraiment un compagnon ou en tout
cas un être vivant qui mérite notre
attention je voudrais m'arrêter sur une
mesure qui m'a un petit peu interpellé
vous souhaitez interdire la consommation
de viande de cheval dans pour quelles
raisons
est ce qu'on considère le cheval comme
un comme un boeuf ou comme un mouton ou
est ce qu'on considère plutôt comme un
chien comme une menace comme un animal
de compagnie on va pas
on
va on va pas monter un boeuf le week end
on va faire du on va faire du cheval on
aux enfants ils vont faire du poney et
ainsi de suite voilà donc ces on est là
on élève les chevaux pour faire des
activités avec eux pas pour pas pour les
manger je jure qu on veut faire une
petite remarque là dessus sur les
chevaux la banque de ma campagne pour
les législatives j'avais invité nicolas
sarkozy à un centre hippique
voilà pour faire une petite vidéo et
parler delà de la maltraitance qui était
faite aux chevaux ça c'est a priori
calme et il avait accepté l'invitation
il était venu et il avait adoré y avait
un ciel magnifique il y avait le la
personne en charge du dressage et des
animaux qui étaient là qui a passé son
temps avec nous il était vraiment
heureux c'est un homme qui aime les
animaux comme comme beaucoup de gens
cherchent et debout la france est
vraiment voilà les cheveux pour lui ce
sont des animaux de compagnie se sont
pas des c'est pas de la nourriture quoi
enfin sur ce sujet vous souhaitez
déposer un projet de loi reconnaissant
la sensibilité des animaux dans le code
pénal brice que ça changerait dans les
faits
ça changerait
la réglementation sur la maltraitance
qu'on peut leur faire
s'attaquer à des animaux ça n'a pas de
sens voilà enfin
sur les chiens prises pour basso qui
sont des lésions sur actes de cruauté on
s'attaque à un animal eh bien on est
sanctionné par la loi
on abandonne un animal on peu plus haut
un peu plus on adopter un peu plus en
avoir et ainsi de suite
voilà on l'a même façon qu'on ne
s'attaque pas aux êtres humains et qu'on
ne s'attaque pas aux animaux de
compagnie enfin pour finir cette
émission je voudrais venir avec vous en
matière sur la matière la politique
environnementale de debout la france
vous avez quatre priorités la première
donc réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre pour cela comment est ce
que vous vous y prenez quelle politique
énergétique choisissez-vous nucléaire
éolienne solaire géothermie quelle est
la position debout la france sur le
sujet
alors il ya plusieurs mesures qui sont
possibles
déjà une mesure qu'on pourrait faire de
manière simple qui serait de d'améliorer
les transports en commun avec des
moteurs propres ça commence à se faire
ça se fait depuis plusieurs années mais
on pourrait on pourrait essayer de
généraliser sa le
tous les transports publics les
transports publics et en particulier
dans les intercommunalités voilà donc
améliorer les réseaux de transport avec
des transports propres
nucléaire absolument on est pour pour
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
et pour pour une filière qui peut lui
pas et pour nous la solution c'est le
nucléaire alors le nucléaire on va nous
dire fukushima
et d'autres termes de tchernobyl y en a
d'autres mais
voilà ça c'est des technologies qui sont
apparus dans les années 50 ce qu'on
souhaite nous c'est relancer la
recherche
en particulier dans le programme de 2017
c'était très clairement mentionné la
recherche sur les seuls fonds du thorium
que monsieur hulot ne connaissait pas
quand elle a été interviewée à
l'assemblée nationale juste après voilà
donc il ya des filières qui peuvent être
intéressantes il faut relancer la
recherche là dessus ça nous permettra
d'avoir de l'électricité décarbonés et
de garder notre indépendance nationale
deuxième priorité sauver les paysages et
la biodiversité en luttant d'abord
contre l'artificialisation des sols vous
proposé d'alléger la fiscalité sur les
terres non bâti alors aujourd'hui on
encourage trop les propriétaires à
construire selon
absolument absolument à des mesures
lancées je croise était sous monsieur
hollande pour
pour
construire plus pour densifier l'habitat
on peut rajouter des étages et puis et
puis on diminue la surface les pays de
l'ue ont été ont été revus dans ce sens
oui un propriétaire qui a une surface
non bâti eh ben ils payent des taxes à
lui coûte cher donc yvan voilà c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça il faut il faut
revoir
l'intérêt d'avoir des surfaces agricoles
des surfaces non bâti
maître des airs encourager les haines
entre entre les champs avoir des parts
des parcelles plus petites
voilà c'est que c'est quand même
agréable de se lever le matin avec avec
le chant des oiseaux ou d'avoir des
papillons quand on va se promener dans
la campagne autour de nos villes à la
plaine de versailles est un bon exemple
troisième priorité en matière de
politique environnementale faire de
l'économie circulaire une réalité
quotidienne pour cela vous souhaitez
lutter contre l'obsolescence programmée
notamment comment est ce que vous vous
faites
il ya un moment il faut légiférer
l'obsolescence programmée vous achetez
une imprimante les garanties un an et en
bande en panne un an et un jour après
parce qu'il ya des éléments qui ont été
ajoutés afin qu'elles soient plus
fragiles
donc il faut avoir
des contraintes pour que les matériels
soient plus plus solide plus robuste et
puis à côté continuer à mettre en place
des filières
de réparation et de recyclage
enfin dernière priorité pour terminer
cette émission protéger la santé humaine
vous proposer la mise en place de cours
de santé bien-être au collège pour
sensibiliser les adolescents aux
conséquences que peuvent avoir par
exemple leur alimentation c'est selon
vous un manque qui existe aujourd'hui
dans l'éducation nationale
très clairement oui
l'école va nous enseigner beaucoup de
choses sur les écoles de saint-cyr par
exemple il ya des cours dès le primaire
peut-être le mans enfin dès le primaire
sur le tri sélectif sur le recyclage on
va voir une usine de un centre de
recyclage par exemple et les enfants
quand ils rentrent à la maison si on on
met une canette dans la mauvaise
poubelle églises n'ont pas pas c'est pas
du tout comme ça qu'il faut faire donc
ce qu'on apprend aux enfants en primaire
en particulier sur le recyclage sur le
bien-être c'est des choses qu'ils vont
acquérir qu'ils vont mémoriser et qu'ils
vont partager ensuite donc c'est le bon
moment et c'est une bonne matière
avec avec la géographie et l'histoire à
de l'outre-mer merci beaucoup pauline
également d'avoir été avec nous dans la
biopolitique merci à vous rappelle que
vous êtes le secrétaire départemental
debout la france dans les yvelines et
nous on se retrouve en janvier pour un
nouveau numéro de l'aide aux politiques
bonne fin d'année à tous
[Musique]
les politiques